そこで一応今日は三つ説明しましたね
どうも理解しがたいし
巧妙に逃げるしね 演出して逃げちゃうし
そちらにはすごい矛盾というものが成り立っているし
いくらいくら心と言ったって好きなところに粘りすぎる
というえらい単純さもあります
そういうことは心なんです
そこでここまでの説明を聞くと
もう携わることもできない
あまりにも巨大でどうにもならないエネルギーでしょ？心っていうのは
そこでお釈迦様は光の希望の光を与えてくる
それはちょっと管理すればものすごく幸せになるんだよと
心の言うことを聞くんじゃないよと
それは制御してみなさいと
で チッタッサダンマトーサ
チッタンラッケータメーダーヴィ
ちょっと知恵があるんだったら
これちょっとガードしておけばいいんじゃないかなと
チッタングッタン 心をガードしておけば
心は暴走しない もうきちんと管理されて
すごい丁寧に動いているんだよということだったら
極端に幸せになるんだよと
それであの永遠な苦しみが消えちゃうんです
心を守ってない生き方っていうのは
まあ苦しむことには決まっている
何をしても結果は苦しみということになる
それで心はちょっとガードしてみると
そこで初めて幸せっていうことを味わえます
この芸のね 基本的な意味は単純ですからね
心守りましょうと 心守ればもう幸せになるんだよというふうなことで日本訳されていると思いますし
それ以上説明はまあ皆様も認めたくないしね
そういう気持ちはわかっているしね
日本の先生方はそう訳しているんだからね
それ以外意味あるはずないと思ってるでしょ
まあいろいろ意味がありますけどね
一応それはそれでね でも我々にはそんな難しいことは覚えられませんから
大変でしょうしね この大量のことを覚えるっていうことですから
ただ心っていうのは守った方がありがたいことで
幸せになるんだなっていうぐらいの省略して覚えておけば決して悪くないんです
心は守れば幸せだと 怒らない
どういうふうに守りますかね
怒らないように守る 欲張らないように守る
感情は発作を起こさないように守る
混乱しないようにと 常に落ち着いているようにと心を守る
常識な人間っていうのはね
大体は何でもチェックするでしょ
鍵かけたかガスを もうガスなんて閉めたかとかね
電気を消したかとかね
要は俺がチェックしないそうと言ったっても
こんな生き方っていうのは良くないでしょうに
私は赤信号なんか見てやるもんか
そんなのは 私は堂々と渡るぞと言えば
一応知識の人は言わないでしょうに
知識のある人は たとえ青信号を渡っても
それでもちょっと情労にはチェック入れるでしょうに
だから心は暴走しないようにと
感情が爆発しないようにとかね
怒りが出ないようにとか
欲が出ないようにとか
混乱しないようにとかね
ちょっとチェックを入れておけば
それで幸せになります
そのチェックをしてるつもりなのは
実は演じとるだけっていうことがよくあるような感じなんですけども
まあその人には救いの道がないんですね
だから一人が自分でやることだから
演じることにはならないし
それさえも演じようとするならばね
病気な人に じゃあこれは薬だよと言ったところで
先生を騙すと 見事に薬飲んだぞと言ったら
もう救いの方ないでしょ
だからこの集団的な修行ではなくて
個人個人で自分のためだからね
だから我は私の仏教の説法の態度はそういうものも勝手にやれよと
私に関係ないんだと というのは失礼な態度じゃなくて
それは正しい説法の態度なんです
怒らないように気を付けて
そんなこと言ったってもう
じゃあ勝手にやれば だから言ってあげることはこちらの責任で
それ以外言ってはいけないんです
正しい仏教の場合は そうすると本人が怒ったら私が損するんであって
怒りをコントロールすれば私が幸せになるんであって
なんで私はそこまで心配しなくちゃいけないんですかね
だから怒るなよという
怒ってしまいますから
そう わかった こういう方法を教えてあげましょうというふうに
怒らない方法もちょっと教えてあげる
しかし 個人がやっぱりこれやった方が私のためになるんだよと言って
素直に一人でやらなくちゃいけないんですね
素直に一人でやると演出することがなくなっちゃうんです
では みんなで怒らないように頑張りましょうと言っちゃう
それは明らかにもう みんなでニコニコ笑いましょうと言っちゃうと
明らかに嘘なんですね
そこはもういい質問ですけど
そこはすごい大事なポイントなんですね
自分にぐらい素直になりなさいと
私たちには仮面かぶって演出したってもいいんだけど
自分自身にも仮面かぶっちゃうと
もうどうにもならないんですね
面白いことはそういう人間見るんですよ
自分に言い返して 自分に向かって演出する
もうどうにもならない人々なんですよ
困ったことに だから一人で悔しがった方がいいんですよ
例えば もう人の前ですごく丁寧に敬語を使って
もうすごい洗練した振り舞いを全部やって
もうみんなに褒められて褒めてもらって
部屋に帰ったとたんに
一人でとんでもない もう苦しい
こんなやり方で嫌やとかね
それはいいんですよ 別に
だから演出したこと自体苦しみだからね
だから仏教でいう心清らかなする方法も
一人勝手に悔しがってやった方が正直でうまくいくんですよ
いや この人生はいつでも怒ったりしてね
怒るたびに私は損しているんではないかと
不幸になるんではないかと
こんな生き方なんかとんでもないやと
勝ってやるぞということで
じゃあこれからはもう自分が怒り
怒りが生まれないようにチェックを入れておくことぞと言って
ただ自分だけの世界なの
それは みんなに褒めてもらうためじゃないんです
だから 他人の影響は気にしないで
他人の誘惑を気にしないで
みんなごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃいろんなことを言うと
どんどんどんどん怒りが込み上がってくるでしょうね
込み上がって そんな時は
怒らないように気をつける
その方が私が楽やとかね
で 自分の心にチェックしておこう
そのチェックしておいたところで
やっぱりこの連中はどうしても怒りたがっているんだと
でも私が怒らないんだと
でもこんなややこしいことは終わらない
怒ってあげなきゃと思って
それで怒りは演出できますよ
その場合はド派手に怒ったような感じでいろんなことできます
それでもやっぱり怒った
もう怖い 逃げましょうと
それで本人がバカというふうに感じてね
落ち着くでしょうに だから怒ることと怒りの演出はまた違う
だから本当に穏やかな人には怒りの演出はできる
まあそれは具体的な例言ってますけど
ある自分の仲間のグループに行ったところで
仲間がいろんなことを言う
もう自分を怒らせたくていじめをする
でも自分がそれを気を決めた
いじめられるたびに悔しい思いでするんだから
人生は苦しいんだと だから今度は今度からもう怒らないことにすると
その方が気持ち気分が穏やかだと
一定ところでまた向こうはいじめ始める
いじめてもいじめても
こちらは怒らないで すごく穏やかにニコニコしている
そうすると向こうはどんどんいじめエスカレートするでしょうね
今日はおかしいと それでも自分が穏やかにする
そうすると向こうはもっとエスカレートするんですね
いじめは 大体人間ではそこら辺ではもう糸が切れちゃうんです
もう忍耐のレベルが切れちゃって
もう爆発するでしょ それはもう負けなんですね
その時はそれでも落ち着いていて
この人々はね 私は怒らない限りはやめないね
これはとか では怒ってでもあげようかなと
言って 嫌な気分を見せたり
怒鳴ったり けなしたり
いろんなことをしたりする
やっぱり怒りましたということで
向こうは勝ったつもりでもう終わっちゃうでしょうね
でも自分がこんなバカたちやっていう感じで楽しい
家に早く帰ったっても悔しくはない
なんで仲間にいじめられなくてはいけないんでしょうかっていうことはなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 自分の気持ちにチェックを入れておくぐらいで心を守られます
すごい幸せにいられます
何が悪いかと基本的に言えば
すぐ欲を出してはいけない
あれこれには なぜかというと
心は本来好きなところに行くに決まってるんですね
だからそこら辺を気をつけた方がいいんですよ
なぜかと それはいい餌になっちゃうんで
他の人には 世の世界っていうのは
いつでも餌をまいて罠を仕掛けて待ってるんです
そこで私の心は好きなものにポッといっちゃいますからね
すぐもう罠に引っかかっちゃうんですよ
ですから まず欲を出さないことにチェックを入れる
まあどうしてもこれぐらいはどうしても必要だっていうところにだけ
そういうものだけ買ったりする
見たりする という感じで欲もコントロールする
音楽だからって何でも聴くんじゃなくて
まあまあ 1 日 30 分ぐらいはなんとか新しい音楽ぐらい聴いておいた方がいいんじゃないかなというところで
ちょっとチェックを入れる
食い物だからって何でも食うんじゃなくて
まあどうせ体にはこれぐらいのものは必要でしょう
だったらそこら辺は美味しいものを食べましょうと
そういう風に欲にもチェックを入れる
怒りにも完全にチェックを入れる
怒った時点で負けますからね
混乱にもチェックを入れる
混乱したところで失敗しますからね
それから反対に言えば
常に落ち着いているということのチェックして
それを守る 落ち着いている
混乱がないので落ち着いているならば
まあ大体これぐらいでは十分だなと思います
その芸の説明は これこの芸を教えるために何か逸話エピソードあるんだぞと言ってエピソードあるんですけど
これが明らかに作り話やと思いますね
このお釈迦様の時代ではそんなこと起きたかどうかちょっとわかりません
別にストーリー言いますから
これは作り話 なんでそういうことを言いますかとね
西城の方にある西家の在家の人がいたんだと
その人が自分が知ってるお坊さんがいて
そのお坊さんのところに行って
私は苦しみから脱出したいんだと
解脱をしたいんだと 仏教では涅槃に入りたいと言わないんですよ
苦しみを乗り越えたいと言うんです
普通はね 初期仏教テーラワーダ仏教ではね
苦しみを乗り越えるという言葉使ってます
ですから 私は苦しみを乗り越えたい
苦しみとかはないんだから教えてちょうだいと
そうすると そのお坊さんがそんなに苦しみから苦しみを乗り越えたいんですか？と
だったら まあお坊さんたちにお布施ぐらいしなさいよと
こちらサラーカバッタンというのは
日にち決めて 週一回 月一回とかね
日にちを決めてお布施しなさいと
パッカバッタンというのは
二週間に一回とかね ワッサーワーシカンというのてあって
もうお坊さんで暗号とか入りますから
暗号をあげたら色々お布施する儀式があって
そういうものをやりなさいと
それから出家に必要な衣やら他のものやらね
お布施しなさいよと それで終わらなくて
自分の財産をね ちゃんと三頭に分けて
三つに分けて 財産の3分の1を仕事に投資しなさいよと
商売に3分の1を家族で楽しく生活するために自分で使ってくださいと
3分の1を仏教のために使ってくださいと
仏教を広めるために ということで
そんな話は経典ではないんですけど
本当は これ強引に書いてるような感じがします
だってこの四頭に分けるということは仏教で言ってますよ
お釈迦様がね 財産をね
三頭に分けて一つ欠けてますよ
この貯金しなさいというところはね
そこでこの人がよくおとなしい人でよくわかりましたと
それから言った通りに頑張ったと
お布施することにしても
3頭に分けて3分の1がありますからね
それでやることだからやっていたんだと
まあなんかこの在家の方がこれだけでは苦しみを乗り越えたということにはなりませんし
もっとやらなくちゃいけないことないのかと聞いたところでありますと
だったら三帰依をしなさいと
五回ぐらい回りなさいと
よくわかりますと で 三帰依をして五回を回ることになるんですね
でも納得いかない それでもっとやることはないんでしょうかと
だったら何でしたっけ？だったら十回をね
十種類の戒律を五回足らない
十回十回守りなさいと
そういう風にお坊さんが言う通りに
何でも素直にやるんだから
彼にアダナまでつけちゃったんですね
アダナはちょっと日本語はできない
あの  もう 何でも言う通りにやる
何て言いますかね 日本語は現代日本語でそういうニュアンス違う
なんかロボット人間みたいですけど
でもニュアンスはロボット人間ちょっと違う
言うことはちゃんとはいはいはいはい
わかりましたということで
淡々と素直にやるという意味で
とにかく頭までつけたら付けられてしまったんですね
そこで十回まで守ってるんですけど
この人はこれで苦しみ乗り越えたでしょうか
ということがあって もっともっと上のないんですかと
もっと上の上の宿題はと
もっと上 じゃああんた出家しなさいよと
もっと上だったらと はい
わかりましたと この人は出家する
そこからですね 問題起こるのは
そこで彼の戒律授けてあげるお坊さんというのは
この教式の親と呼ぶんですね
親になったお坊さんは戒律の専門家なんです
そこで師匠がアビダルマのプロなんです
心理学の 弟子はだいたい師匠のところに行ったり
親の親と呼ぶ先生のところに行ったりとかね
行ったり来たり だいたい親という先生のところにはそれほどいないんですけど
普通の自分の師匠のところにはいるし
とにかく行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり生活するのは普通なんです
それで この人は自分の師匠のところに行ったら
ものすごいゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャアビダルマの心理学とかね
仏教ではこういうことです
こういうことです そればっかり言うんですね
しかし その人 そのお坊さん知らないんだから
これはやってはいけないよとかね
これはやりなさいよとかね
それは一つも教えられないんだと
ただ 真実はどれぐらいあるのかという説明はできます
で 道徳とか何も教えられることはできない
それで上のお坊さんのところに行ったら
比丘はこれはやってはいけません
これはやってはいけません
こういう風にこういう風に生活するのと生活することだけを教えてくれる
そこでこの人はもうあきらめちゃったんです
私はもう苦しみを乗り越えたいと思って出家したのに
私にはもう手を伸ばす余裕もないんだと
あの先生のところに行ったら難しい
いろんなことをアビダルマやらもう言うは言うは言うは
これを覚えるのは大変で
もう暇ないほど で この先生のところに行ったら
これやってはいけない
この歩き方は間違い この衣の着方がまずい
この座り方間違ってる
この喋り方間違ってるとかね
もうこれどうすればいいのかとね
もうすごい迫られた気分になったんですね
これでは意味がない 還俗するんだと
苦しみなくなるどころか
もう息苦しくなっちゃったんですね
還俗するんだと決めた途端
それでも出家でいるんだから
もう嫌でいるんだからね
どんどん顔色が悪くなっちゃって
痩せ始めて もう元気がなくなっちゃって落ち込んじゃっていると
また他の若いお坊さんたちは
またなんであんた落ち込んでるんでしょうか？とかね
元気がないでしょうとか
また言われる 本当に元気がなくなって病気になりかけていたんです
それでその人は本当は私はもう還俗したいんですけど
もう嫌やと この生活はと嫌と言いながらやってますから
ものすごく病気になっちゃったんですね
それでこれがまあ お釈迦様のところに引っ張られて
あんたどうなってるんでしょうかというと
お釈迦様には正直にことを言う
私はこういうこういう経歴があって出家してるんだと
それが苦しみを乗り越えたいんですけど
それでせっかく出家する羽目になりまして
出家したのはいいんだけど
もう真教主のところに行っちゃうと
もうヴィネヤ言われる戒律のこと
これもう一生勉強したっても終わりきらないほどヴィネヤの学問ですからね
アビダルマに入っちゃうと一生も足らんほど量があるんですよ
これはあちらからアビダルマで攻めて
こちらからヴィネヤ攻めちゃって
自分がどうすればいいかというとわからなくなって
先生たちも必死だから
やっぱりもう徹底的に教えてあげて一人前にしたいでしょうしね
だから辞めるしかないんだと
でお釈迦様はなるほど
あんたもう守ることを決めること
勉強することありすぎですね
あなたには だったら全部やめてくださいと
やめて一つだけ守られますかということで
こんなのアビダルマでもどうでもいいやと
戒律そんなのどうでもいいんだから置いといて
一つだけ守ることにしてください
一つならできますか？と
どうせ元々すごい正直なマニュアル人間マニュアル人間だから
言われる通りにやる人だからね
まあ一つだけだったら大丈夫だと
守れますよということで
だったらね 自分自身の心だけ守ってみなさいよ
ためにはこれとお釈迦様が
そんなゴチャゴチャ言う必要ないでしょ
アビダルマはどうでもいいでしょう
戒律なんかいくらあったっていいんじゃないんだ
そんなのは そんなので戦うんじゃなくて
自分の心ぐらい守りなさいよと
これぐらいのことでしょうと
いうことで 智慧のある人は自分の心守るんだよと
それでこの話 お釈迦様のその話を聞いて
誰か喜びに悟るんです
で やっと気づいて やっぱり自分で自分の心管理すればよかった
初めからそれだけのことでしたけど
人に委ねる 委ねて人に自分の心を委ねてろくなことにならなかったという話なんです
自分で守ればよかったのにね
だからこのストーリーはね
ちょっと怪しいんですよ
なぜかというと これはブッダの後はそういう生き方
アビダルマのプロがいて
ヴィニヤのプロがいて
学問的に生徒弟子たちをね
もう徹底的に調教させちゃうし
修行なんかはもうあっと言う間に時間なくなっちゃって
これは明らかに後の時代のことなんですけどね
でもブッダの時代でも何人かはいたんですよ
この戒律項目は勉強できなくて
暗記でやらなくちゃいけないし
もう難しすぎて もう数多すぎて
あれは六法という何か読むような感じですよね
これ読んだっても覚えられないでしょうに
民法やらいろいろあるでしょ
刑法なんとか何とかとか
あんな分厚い本なんかはもう読んでも読んでもね
もう刑法何々番でこうこうあるんだけど
誰が覚えられますか そんなのは
もう嫌になっちゃいますよ
だからそんな感じで覚えなくたっていいんだから
とにかくそもそも戒律
法律を破らなきゃいいでしょ
別に 六法を知らなくても
我々そもそもおとなしく生活すれば
もう例えば本当はこの道路の脇とか公のところでは小便出してはいけないんですよ
罰金なんです そんなのは知っていてもね
あまり日本では別にそれは調べませんからいいんですけど
でも本当はそれやってはいけないことで
でも自分たちがおとなしく生活すれば
そういう微妙な法律さえも破れないんですよ
簡単です 警察さえ知らない法律までも自分が守っていることになるんです
そういう法律の場合も同じことだから
仏教の場合も同じことで
ものすごい難しいことをガチャガチャ知らなくたっても
自分だけ落ち着いていれば
大体 ものは事は済みますよと完璧に
ということで話を終了します
どうもありがとうございます